[Music]
in both splendor and abundance
one flower on this planet outshines the
rest
each spring the dutch lowlands are set
aflame
by myriads of brightly coloured blossoms
this might be the best known plant in
the world
but who knows its secret history
the beauty of this flower has intrigued
beguiled
and bewitched rich and poor alike
once its bulbs were worth their weight
in gold
three centuries ago its luxurious
patterns and hues
crazed an entire nation
its bulbs became the object of fantastic
financial speculation
astronomical bets were placed on their
rising price
but when the market crashed thousands of
investors
tumbled into ruin
it was the first big bust in the history
of booms
the burst of the tulip bubble
[Music]
the netherlands in february 1637
the news spread like wildfire
for the first time a tulip auction had
fallen
short of expectations
over months prices had soared to
fantastic levels
but suddenly tulips were no longer
bought
overnight treasured contracts turned
into trash
dreams of super profits had not lasted
long
the value of a coveted commodity had
proven volatile
[Music]
the tulip fever had infested a large
part of the netherlands population
everyone wanted to profit from the
rising demand for these colorful flowers
[Music]
but now the party was over
[Music]
those with little capital were hit the
hardest people from all walks of life
had been infected by the craze laborers
craftsmen
and gamblers
people like adrian the miller
[Music]
it was crazy a true mania a too
speculative bubble
because it made no sense that anybody
would
bet on an ever increasing price
of a flower
economist peter m garber is a market
analyst for a major international bank
there are obvious parallels between the
17th century tulip fever
and developments in today's financial
markets
in both situations people were and are
betting
unrealistically on rising prices
why do people stumble into the very same
trap over centuries
british historian mike dash has been
wondering about this question
there is something in the human mind in
the human spirit
which makes us not want to believe the
truth
about stock market bubbles
most people participate in a bubble in
spite of better knowledge
this was made apparent for the first
time by the 17th century tulip mania
during the first half of the 17th
century
the netherlands had an exceptional
position in europe
while the rest of the continent was
devastated by the 30 years
war the netherlands enjoyed their golden
age
[Music]
it was the era of dutch painting of
great masters
like rembrandt franz house
rubens and vermeer
thanks to the overseas trade the
national economy
was booming
the netherlands were not ruled by a
costly royalty
their autonomous cities and provinces
were governed by councils of citizens
and gentry the key to understanding the
netherlands
early in the 17th century is that it was
a very special sort of country
it was the first country in europe to
develop a modern economy
and it was also the wealthiest country
in europe and it based
that wealth on trade it was the first
country
which was able to establish direct
trading links in a major way with the
far east
and this is where most of the luxury
goods came from in this period and by
taking all of those little slices of
profit
and keeping them to themselves dutch
merchants became extraordinarily wealthy
although capital remained concentrated
in the hands of a few
the general public also enjoyed a higher
standard of living than in the rest of
europe
this was the case for craftsmen as well
as for the domestics
like anna
[Music]
the problem that the dutch merchants had
in this period was that they had gone
through the reformation in the previous
century and holland was in fact
in the grip of a rather extreme form of
calvinism
this frowned greatly on any sort of
ostentatious displays of wealth
the only thing that these dutch
merchants were really allowed socially
to do with their wealth
was to display it in the form of things
that glorified god and this really
explains
a large part of the dutch obsession with
gardens
a coveted decorative element of dutch
gardens was the tulip
an exotic plant native to central asia
[Music]
in the cold steps and mountain regions
of kazakhstan
the wild ancestors of dutch tulip breeds
are still found today
they are somewhat smaller than our
garden varieties and display many
beautiful hues
from red to orange and gold
[Music]
from central asia tulips were first
taken to turkey
where they enjoyed special appreciation
as harbingers of spring
in the second half of the 16th century
the first tulips arrived in europe
to adorn the palace grounds of emperor
rudolf ii
in vienna and prague from there botanist
charles de la cruz
brought tulips to the netherlands
at the university of leiden lecleus
founded a garden named hortus academicus
where the first tune of variety he bred
can still be admired today
very soon this exquisite plant would
cast a spell
on the entire nation
[Music]
including adrian the miller
[Music]
adrian was engaged in the game of trick
track
when he noticed some hustle and bustle
in the tavern's back room
[Music]
these people seem to be trading
something something
of great value
[Music]
lots of flower bulbs and lots of money
were changing hands
and anyone was welcome to join in
adrian saw his lucky chance
if you grew up in harlem and you're a
miller
and you try to predict on the basis of
what you know about
that market and the fundamentals that
drive it try to predict what
the future price will bring you may be
wrong
[Music]
any speculative investment is driven by
the desire to
make high returns and the tulip mania
was no different from that
the only unusual aspect was where and
how the deals were made
[Music]
what you actually had was a sort of
imitation of the real life economy which
emerges amongst artisans and peasants
who
really don't really know exactly how
this is done they would form their own
little
stock exchanges or trading groups which
normally met in
pubs so a large part of the tudor trade
also took part in a sort of haze of
intoxication
which made people more willing to take
risks on things that are actually less
trustworthy first
each bulb was weighed
the seller wrote the price he wanted on
a slate which he handed to the chairman
then the would-be buyers wrote down
their offers
[Music]
the chairman fixed a price somewhere
between the seller's expectation
and the highest offer
adrian made his move for a tiny brown
bulb
he spent his last gilda
there is maybe some leader that invests
in
a project but everyone else in the herd
just
follows on the basis of that person's
doing the investment and they just throw
their money
into the project without understanding
perhaps what is
going on
adrian had no experience with tulips he
had never possessed any
all he knew was the demand for tulips
was going up
[Music]
the deals in harlem's shady backrooms
heralded the growth of a huge industry
today eighty percent of all the tulips
sold worldwide
are produced in the netherlands
each spring brightly colored flower
fields spread from horizon
to horizon
[Music]
so
but most of these blossoms will never
leave the netherlands
these are just crop fields and the
harvest
is bulbs
once the blossoms have withered the
bulbs are on earth like potatoes
cleaned and sorted
at this time mother and daughter bulbs
are separated
this form of asexual propagation
provides new bulbs for breeding
[Music]
back in the 1700s dutch gardeners
also unearthed the bulbs after flowering
[Music]
this was to prevent voles and other
pests from eating the juicy bulbs of
these luxury plants
[Music]
but another reason even back then was to
get the daughter bulbs in order to raise
identical flowers of each breed
[Music]
handling these tiny daughter bulbs
correctly requires green fingers
[Music]
something had dropped in front of anna's
feet and no one had noticed
now she held her own little bulb in her
hands
surely a flower of exquisite beauty
would grow from it next spring
but no one was to know
anna carefully wrapped her unspectacular
gem
and hid it in her room
her treasure was to be kept safe and
secret
[Music]
adrian for his part also appreciated
tuna bulbs
but for a different motive
over the summer tulip prices had been
steadily climbing
the more people joined the speculation
game the faster prices rose
adrian threw his little bulb on the
market in just a short while
he made a handsome profit
but a good profit depended on which
variety of tulip you bought
and sold
[Music]
when we looked today at tulips you might
think that they were beautiful but they
are not the tulips that the dutchman of
the 17th century saw
they were even more vivid and colorful
and the value of achilles was extremely
closely tied up to the colours on it and
the finer those colours were the more
highly esteemed the bulb was
[Music]
to this day there are tulips with
extravagant color combinations
and extraordinary patterns
and still many of the threats to these
delicate plants
remain
[Music]
the greatest threat to tulip bulbs is
not the appetite
of our little neighbors
[Music]
the most insidious enemy is hidden deep
inside
the very cells of the plant
[Music]
a virus
today these germs are well researched
but in the 17th century they brought
surprises to tulip breeders
because a virus can radically alter the
appearance of a plant
a virus cannot live by itself it needs
another organism
viruses can only multiply within the
cells of a host
margaret lymer to kamara mercado is a
plant virus expert
the viruses are specialists in
reprogramming plant cells
causing havoc in a plant's normal
development by reinforcing
some genes and deactivating others
when the pigment production in some
cells are super activated
the result can be dark red stripes
when the pigment production is stifled a
bright white stripe will appear
or dots creating special patterns
plants plant viruses are being spread in
various ways
this particular tulip break in virus is
being spread by aphids
an aphid sucking at an infected plant
can then infect a healthy one it's easy
to imagine
how quickly an entire field can be
infected
when so many plants are so close
together
until this day this virus poses a
massive problem for tulip breeders
you can only fight it manually the
breeders patrol their fields so they can
immediately remove suspicious plants and
stop the spread of the disease
but then again it was precisely this
viral infection that produced the most
extravagant 17th century tulips
flame flowers with stripes and curly
edges
to produce a beautiful flower you have
to have the bulb to do it
and the more unique the bulb is the more
you
tend to value it now why would a
particularly new
a unique and new variety of bulb have a
high value a very high value
so so high that it might equal the price
of a substantial house
as it did in the netherlands well that's
because that bulb reproduces
the expectation of increasing a plant's
value by one or two hundred percent
fired the imagination of investors
back then little was known about the
biology behind the tulips reproduction
but catalogues listing tulip breeds
existed
[Music]
due to the nature of its bulb the tuna
is an ideal trade commodity
bulbs can survive without soil for many
months
they are also easy to transport store
and handle a tulip bulb
is a storage organ which enables the
plant to survive
periods of drought or a long and very
a certain period at low temperatures is
even needed to trigger
new growth
[Music]
as soon as the spring weather offers the
right combination of light
warmth and moisture the ball
begins to sprout
[Music]
within a short time a large plant will
grow
from a comparatively little bulb
[Music]
during the second half of 1637
tulips with a rare flaming pattern
fetched a hundred gilders per bulb
the equivalent of four fat pigs or a
thousand pounds of cheese
to encourage extravagant patterns
bizarre methods were applied
some even tried to manipulate flower
colors by storing bulbs
in red wine
[Music]
although today's methods make more sense
the results are still
far from certain
in spite of elaborate computer modelling
breeders cannot always predict what will
happen when they cross breed various
tulips
the solution is to try several cross
breeds
and then select the prettiest and
toughest ones
and that requires patience
it takes years until a new breed will
blossom for the first time
sometimes an entire decade passes after
the first pollination
until breeders can really judge the
qualities of a new breed
[Music]
thanks to their uncomplicated bulbs
tulips are an ideal trade commodity
but bulbs have one major disadvantage
the appearance of a bulb tells you
nothing about the looks of its flower
so the purchase of tulip bulbs has
always been a matter of trust
and trust has often been abused
the tuna trade did have to involve a
certain amount of trust
it's very hard for us to know the
records are rather scant
exactly how much people believed in what
they were being told
each bulb carries its own secret until
next spring
and that turns any business deal into a
gamble
some breeders tried to limit the risk of
evil surprises
by careful sorting and cataloguing
if by coincidence well sorted stocks
were mixed up
the result could be a nightmare
[Music]
even with perfect organization a certain
risk
[Music]
remains
the most valuable specimens would be the
ones infected by the virus
but traders had no way of recognizing
infected bulbs
[Music]
the fact that the flowers are infected
means it's very hard to predict what's
going to happen the next time the bulb
flowers
it may or may not produce one of these
broken tulips
which are fantastically valuable
sometimes a dutchman would buy
an ordinary tulip and it would become
infected and it next year it would
flower into something incredibly
valuable
so a huge element of chance is also
introduced into the trade
which for a certain sort of trader makes
it even more attractive
[Music]
to gain the buyers confidence traders
use the mastery skills of dutch painters
in a new way one of the extraordinary
things that then developed in the
netherlands in the 1630s was the
development of what's known as tulip
books and these were books produced
often
on commissioned by very wealthy tulip
traders who would pay
artists to actually illustrate the types
of children they had
in their inventory these tulip books are
our best source of information about
historic flowers
or at least of an artist's flowering
[Music]
imagination
these pictures are very beautiful they
show tulips of the most
exotic fineness but you're still
trusting that the person who's showing
you this picture
does actually own the bulb and there's
still lots of scope there for
all sorts of chicanery and mistrust
[Music]
these gorgeous images were further
enhanced with glorious names
such as admiral van der ike
or ruth van leiden
[Music]
i think it would be fair to suggest that
the tulip books were in effect a form of
early advertising
and there was a very definite commercial
element to this
the books were undoubtedly used as an
advertising medium sort of
as a trade catalog effectively to try to
persuade people
many traders had never seen a live tulip
in full bloom
adrian too is impressed by masterful
illustrations
three centuries later the tulip trade
has changed no other market on the globe
can boast a greater turnover of tulips
than all smear flower market
trading takes place in a hall the size
of several football fields
each year billions of plants pass
through this hall
the shipping area is a perfectly
synchronized logistics machine
cut flowers are an extremely perishable
commodity
[Music]
tulips only flower for a few weeks in
spring
to extend the harvesting period cut
flowers are bred in greenhouses
here they are brought to flower in
successive periods
under controlled conditions
to accelerate sales flower exchanges
like the one in elsmere
operate in the so-called dutch auction
mode
this means counting downward from an
announced maximum price
a good deal depends on the right moment
of placing a bid
if you bid too early the price may be
too high
if you wait too long another trader may
snatch away the commodity
money and merchandise change hands
immediately which is known
as a spot market
this is the key difference from what
went on in 1636
and this is to do with the tulips growth
[Music]
cycle
bulbs must be planted in autumn so they
can flower
in spring
[Music]
special attention was paid to the
arrangement of varieties
and colors
[Music]
that depended on careful sorting at the
time of harvest
and on well organized storage
banner's secret bulb too the time had
come to be planted
a tulip can also flower in a pot
if conditions emulate those outdoors
[Music]
the key is a cold period during winter
[Music]
no problem in anna's unheated chamber
the nature of the tular bulbs is that
they flower
in the spring and the flowers last for a
week or two
and then the bulbs can be dug up and
traded
as as physical items for a few months
for the winter they must go back into
the ground
otherwise they will die so any trading
of bulbs
in the autumn or in the winter by its
very nature was a forward
market they would be delivered when they
came out of the ground
in june in other words the traders
warehouses were empty in winter
dulcer made good use of that period they
invented a new method of trading
when you're dealing with people who are
attempting to make money by trading
bulbs
only being able to make money for a few
weeks of the year isn't a very adequate
answer
and the natural extension of this was to
trade
the possession of the bulb
the way in which the dutch adapted this
is quite fascinating because essentially
what they did was to invent what we
would now consider to be the futures
trade
prices of the physical bulbs did not
move that much
it was the forward markets that moved a
lot and that they diverged dramatically
from the value of the spot price
[Music]
it was the beginning of a new era
now it was possible to sell goods you
did not yet
have
[Music]
you did not buy actual bulbs
you bought the right to purchase bulbs
for a set price
at a future time to give somebody
something else
to say you own this bulb which is in
this garden in this town
owned by such and such a person and if
you take him this piece of paper
he will hand over your property to you
in the back rooms of their pubs with
nothing more than pen and paper
the dutch had invented virtual trading
to make the absence of goods easier to
bear
fantastic paintings provided a visual
impression of the goods
while the real plant was still
slumbering in the soil
of some field up until
october these were strictly futures or
forward prices that is
the buyer of that contract took the
downside risk
as well as the upside gained
many of these old trading contracts
still exist
these historical documents tell a story
of how quickly the trade with paper
contracts
became separated from the physical
commodities
the actual bulbs
oh
the bulbs are effectively coins for them
and the pieces of paper are effectively
banknotes for them they are not
interested at all in growing the plants
and in fact
growing the plants is is a danger to
them because um the way in which
the trade worked was that the the notes
where you have
which you use to claim the ownership of
the flower they have to be settled when
the plant is drawn out of the ground
at that point you have to have a large
amount of money it's far better to
to buy and sell and have the money in
from somebody else and so the trade
becomes increasingly accelerated and
frantic
[Music]
bidders knew well that they were
gambling on fantasy figures
but the temptation of raking in profits
proved irresistible
[Music]
it was called the wind handle which
means you know the
blowing in the breeze essentially and
that conveys a certain amount of the
uncertainty
just the fact there's nothing really
there but wind effectively
that suggests that some dutch people
were aware of what an uncertain trade
the futures trade would actually be
in principle it's the same today once
prices begin
to rise everyone starts buying
[Music]
this works best when there is little
connection between the piece of paper
one buys
and any real commodity or when that
connection
is not understood
[Music]
the general speculation craze was also
fueled by the fact that access to the
market was
cheap compared to the prospect of high
profits
the people involved are usually very
poor they would mortgage their trade
goods the looms that they had
and use that money to put down payments
on tulips and the way in which they
would do it when the bulbs were in the
ground
would be to buy a promissory note from
the person who owned it
a weaver who had just mortgaged his loom
for 25 gilders
would buy 25 guilders worth of tulips
not two and a half guilders worth of
tulips
and save the the balance of 90
knowing you would have to pay that in
the future the prices are rising so high
that seemed to be completely unnecessary
what would happen is you'd invest
everything you could
in as many bulbs as you could and hope
to actually
um transfer your responsibility to
settle the 90
to somebody else before the bulb was
lifted and in that way you could make
more money
that becomes a problem at the very
moment when no buyer is willing to pay
an even
higher price at that moment
panic selling sets in and prices
plummet there is the objective
definition of a bubble
a situation where the prices of an asset
rise very rapidly
and then collapse
something similar happened with the u.s
real estate bubble in 2007.
but between december 1636 and january
1637
tulip prices were still on the rise in
some cases
soaring to astronomical heights
[Music]
the chronicles document the swelling
bubble
the prices of some varieties increased
by one or even
two thousand percent within just a few
weeks
this drove a new sort of demand among
thieves
the rich now had to protect their fields
with alarm systems
at night thieves would dig up the most
valuable bulbs
and throw them on the market
or they stole the very plants they just
sold on paper
[Applause]
the most expensive variety was called
semper augustus
even before the tulip fever its bulbs
had fetched 3 000 gilders
now the price breached the ceiling of 10
thousand
the equivalent of a grand hall in
amsterdam's classiest district
but no one had actually seen the flower
semper augustus is a very interesting
case
it is the most famous flower the tulip
mania and yet it was apparently
never actually traded we certainly can't
say that any particular person
saw the flower we don't know the name of
the person who supposedly owned it
we just know from chronicle that
eventually one of these flowers was
supposedly eventually sold
as with other varieties all of the
traders were able to show was an
artist's impression of the ever joyful
tulip
adrian ii paid good money for a colorful
promise
on paper
[Music]
you can turn to a tulip book and see a
picture of a semper augustus
it is highly highly unlikely that the
person who drew this picture had ever
seen this flower
frankly if you look at this flower and
you look at another
superbly fine red tulip of that period
you can't tell the difference but who
cared the deal was about profit
not a tulip it is possible that central
augustus was effectively an urban myth
on the other hand even if semper
augustus did exist
it can only have been the result of a
viral infection
the mere product of coincidence
theoretically even the bulb awaiting
spring in anna's chili chamber
might grow into a preciously flamed
tulip
perhaps unknown to her she was the owner
of a great treasure
in a flower pot if you want to have
growth
then you start putting your investable
resources your real resources into
somewhat riskier speculative
technologies
if you do that then often you you may
lose you may make a bad investment
and that will at the end look like a
bubble or you may win
[Music]
the danger being caught in possession of
some of these promissory notes and not
having the capital
to meet your 90 commitment became quite
a significant concern for people
this caused sort of flaring up in the
amount of trades
we know from some of the records the
period that bulbs could be bought and
sold at amazed ten times in the day in
one of these
tavern colleges as they were called and
people were obviously trying to shift
their
the liabilities onto somebody else and
this accounts for much
of the frenzy of the tulip mania
some investors including adrian now took
the speculation game a step further
if a crash occurred how could they
profit from that perhaps
adrian could make up for his imminent
loss later on
by buying even more bulbs cheaply after
the crash
and selling them when prices would rise
once more
but most buyers clung to the hope that
prices would just continue to
rise and eventually balance the debt
they had incurred when buying with money
they did not have
they knew that they could not afford to
exit now even if they wanted to
as long as all the others would not exit
everything
would be fine i thought that the uh
tulip speculation in the taverns was
just a drinking game that reflected
demoralization of the society and was
not serious
it was done between people who had very
little wealth
and therefore and they were making very
large bets with each other
with no prospect of collecting on the
beds
modern brokers still face the same key
question as the 17th century tulip
traders
precisely when do you exit
it's an extremely fine line between
maximum profits
and catastrophic losses the watershed is
the moment when prices peak
and just before the market nose dives
into a selling frenzy
a moment that's extremely hard to
anticipate
the speculation when it reached its peak
in
fall and winter of 1636 1637
was purely a a betting market and not
not an actual real investment market
the burst of the bubble took investors
by surprise
in early february 1637 an auction for
tulip bulbs took place
in a tavern and for the first time
nobody bid on one of the lots the
auctioneer
tried to lower the price and auction
them again and for a second time
nobody bit on the flat this is
unprecedented but the implications were
very clear to the people in that tavern
they realized that something very bad
was happening that demand for tulips has
suddenly been cut off
in a moment thousands of dreams were
shattered
people were stunned and horrified
tumbling between sudden realization
denial and disbelief the moment of truth
had hit like a bolt
of lightning they rushed out of the
tavern
to tell their friends sell and the panic
spread throughout harlem so within a day
in harlem
the valley of tulips dropped pretty much
to nothing
panic turns into a stampede as we have
seen with every speculation bubbles
since
accelerated by modern means of
communication a bursting bubble can turn
into a maelstrom
which sucks in personal fortunes banks
industries
currencies and national economies
tearing at the social fabric of our
civilization
in contemporary publications the tulip
traders were lampooned
partially criticized even likened to
monkeys
these images expressed the frustration
and anger of the masses
who felt cheated since then it seems
nothing has changed the tulip mania was
effectively the first financial bubble
that has ever existed and
to be fair to the dutch people of the
early 17th century they had no
particular reason
to know that the bubble could not
continue to expand forever
this had never happened before the idea
that the bubble would inevitably
employed was
unknown to them after the burst of the
tulip bubble dutch authorities saw a
need for trade regulations
as has often happened since a debt
cancellation was decreed
after small investors have been fleeced
leaving them feeling desperate and
frustrated
the authorities may have feared a
[Music]
revolution
just 10 percent of the liabilities the
actual down payment had to be paid when
the contracts became due
and some contracts were even declared
null and void
the reason there was no economic
distress was that there was no
misallocation of invest real investment
resources
[Music]
today financial speculation is deeply
rooted in general society
the bang of a bursting bubble will
reverberate across the globe
and shake society as a whole
we still see examples of exactly these
sorts of bubbles building up and
existing
in our society today and yet still
people continue to make exactly the same
mistakes
adrian's dream is down the drain
for him it's back to milling grain
on anna's windowsill an extravagantly
flamed tulip
greets the sun a few weeks earlier
semper augustus would have made her a
rich lady
now she and her flower are what they've
always been
natural beauties symbols of spring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you